Hello.
My name is Arun
Nagarajan and I'm
a developer advocate at Google.
Today we'll talk about building
iOS apps with Google APIs.
Did you know that Google's
one of the top application
developers on the iOS app store?
We build dozens of
applications for iPhone
and the iPad that are used
by 10s of millions of users.
We also provide a lot APIs and
services to iOS developers,
so that you too can build a lot
of these amazing experiences
for your users.
We are big believers in
reaching users wherever they are
and our tools go beyond
Chrome and Android.
In this session, we'll walk
through several of these APIs
and services that we
provide for iOS developers.
And we'll approach them
in terms of the problem
that you as a developer
might try to solve
and then talk about
the Google API
that we think will help
you immensely in that case.
First, let's talk about building
your application's backend data
store and logic.
Every great application needs a
powerful backend infrastructure
that constantly scales
what the application needs.
Your application's backend might
perform some operations that
are asynchronous or
store some photos
or do push notifications.
There are really a
lot of the scenarios
that you can imagine for an
application that you may build.
And the nice thing
is that Google
has got you covered
with a great service
that we call Google
Cloud Endpoints.
We can build services
on App Engine
and expose them as
APIs for your iOS apps.
And the nice thing is
that these APIs are also
accessible from
Android and web apps,
so you're covered in all fronts.
Here you can see a
server logic in Python--
a really straightforward with
the client-side API called
below it.
And you can see how the server
logic is annotated with the API
semantics and the
client-side API
is generated fully on the
API spec in the server side.
So it feels very natural
and conforming to the API
that you have defined.
Next up, you need to be able to
register and sign in new users.
And this is really important
for a quality application,
because you want to
personalize your application,
store some settings, and be able
to restore to the user's state
and you need to know who
they are at the keyboard.
And Google+ Sign-in for iOS
really lets you solve this very
easily.
Drop in the G+ Sign-in framework
and Xcode and you're off
to the races.
The GPP sign-in instance
will control the registration
and the login flows.
And once the user
is signed in, you
can actually use
the API to request
additional information,
like their profile,
for instance their picture,
or other information
about their social graph itself.
You can even add in
additional scopes,
like access to Google
Drive or calendar,
so that you can securely
interact with those resources
as well.
And all that can be taken
care of in one single sign-in
and authorization flow.
Adding Google+ Sign-in
improves your apps registration
and sign-in rates quite a bit.
As an example, edjing
a DJ app for iOS,
saw an increase of the number
of signed in users on the iPhone
by 32% and their iPad app by 42%
after adding Google+ Sign-in.
So that's quite a bit
of increase there.
And now that you have
your users logged in,
you want to be able
to provide them
with some pretty
immersive experiences.
And the good news is we've
got you covered on that front
as well.
So let's talk about
Google Maps first.
Google Maps provides
high-quality, map imagery,
and information.
You're familiar with that.
And now you can easily embed
Google Maps in your app
as well.
You can easily build
a great map experience
with your custom location
data using Google Maps SDK.
Now here's a small
snippet of code and notice
how we are using
the GMS map view
and providing it a marker
and a camera instance.
And there's some
deeper APIs that
go beyond this to add
further interactivity
or other additional
advanced functionality.
Google Cast enables
multiscreen experiences that
lets your users send and control
content from a small device,
like a phone or tablet, on a
large screen device, like a TV.
So if your app displays video
or other visual content that
would look great
on a big screen,
we highly encourage you to
take advantage of the Cast SDK.
It's really straightforward
to implement.
The flow is first, you
try to scan for devices.
And once you've registered
against a device,
you simply send the media
content up to that device.
The device is called a
receiver and you can actually
customize the look and feel on
the receiver using standard web
technology in case of
advanced scenarios.
If you're a game developer,
we've got a great SDK for you.
It's called Play Games Services.
You can power up your games
with achievements, leaderboards,
real-time multiplayer, and
Cloud Save capabilities.
SDK is across
platforms, so you're
covered on all platforms.
And the user could start
the game on an iOS device
and finish it on a
web browser or compete
against another user on an
Android form, for instance.
Let's take a look at just one
of these features of the Play
Games Services
called leaderboards.
And leaderboards
can be a fun way
to drive competition
amongst your players,
even if they are
just casual gamers.
And here's a simple
example of how
you use the leaderboard using
a GPG leaderboard controller,
which provides a
lot of simple APIs
that you can launch and show
the leaderboard without having
to do much magic.
There are probably
many scenarios
where you want to
embed and show YouTube
content in your application.
Some of the content that you
may have for help, for instance,
or other instructional
information
are really well served by
having that on YouTube.
And the YouTube
iOS Player Helper
is an open-source library
that you can easily
embed into your
application and be
able to show off this
in a simple iframe.
You can see that the YT player
view is a simple library.
And you can see how easy
it is to load and control
a video from there.
Let's now talk about how you
can make your app get better
with time.
You'll of course want to know
how your app is being used--
what the popular sections and
the not so popular sections
are.
And you'll want to be able to
experiment and change things
on the fly, so that you're
not always rebuilding
and resubmitting
your application.
Luckily, we have two
great tools for that.
First, you're probably
familiar with Google Analytics
for websites, but you know that
there's also a Google Analytics
SDK for you iOS native app?
Here you can see how you
can use that SDK-- really
straightforward to track the
analytics of a home screen,
in this example.
And all that, of course, is
securely tracked and logged
in the Google
Analytics web console.
Another great tool
for app developers
is the Google Tag Manager.
Google Tag Manager
allows developers
to change configuration
values in their app
without having to constantly
rebuild and resubmit
their apps.
This is really useful for
changing configuration values
and settings in your
application, like strings
or various UI
settings that you want
to be able to have
dynamic control over.
And this sample snippet shows
how the Tag containers opened
and how the value can be
retrieved using a simple API
call.
Now it's time to talk about
how you can generate money
from your application.
If you're app sells physical
goods, tickets, or services,
you should really look
into Google Wallet.
Google Wallet
Instant Buy enables
you to access
hundreds of millions
of users that use Google Wallet
and can pay via Google Wallet.
And this also minimizes
the data entry
that they have to perform.
So this is a really good
for everybody involved,
including yourself
as the developer.
The two key parts
in the sample code
here are the masked
Wallet request
that defines all
the fields that you
need in order to
create an order.
And the second part talks about
how once order is authorized,
how you can get the proxy
card to send the payment
information to your processor.
Another great way to monetize is
by displaying high-quality ads
in your application.
And you can easily do
that with the AdMob SDK.
Banner ads use a small
portion of the screen
to entice users to click
through to a richer
full-screen experience.
And notice in this
snippet, we're
creating a GAD banner
view and adding
that as a sub-view within your
application UI right there.
So, now to recap.
We walked through ten
different APIs and services
that Google offers
for iOS developers.
As you can see, these APIs help
you solve a lot of the problems
that you as a
developer might have
regardless of the type of
application you're building.
We believe that you could
build amazing experiences
with these APIs for
your users on iOS.
We've just barely scratched
the surface with this APIs.
Feel free to dig in and learn
more at developer.google.com.